sometimes i think back in my life and
i'm amazed to remember the sheer number
of times i've
randomly come across a book while
looking for another book
and why is that
am i just incredibly lucky
is my mind making me believe that this
thing that i accidentally stumbled upon
is important
serendipity is hard to describe because
it sits somewhere between magic and
reality
faith and fact
luck and belief
today i've partnered with hp to try my
best to describe to you how a
series of serendipitous and seemingly
random encounters have led to my thesis
project
[Music]
i was going to call this video how i use
serendipity in my thesis project
but it was just wrong
i didn't really use serendipity serenity
happened to me there's a quote by john
barth from the book the last voyage of
somebody the sailor
you don't reach serendip by plotting a
course for it you have to set out in
good faith or elsewhere
and lose your bearings serendipitously
serendipity is built on happy accidents
but what makes serendipity unique
uh different from the million other
daily encounters that you forget about
is that the accident is meaningful to
you in some way and all we can do is
plant the seeds for those happy
accidents to occur
when i started my masters i had no idea
what i wanted to write my thesis about
but there was a reading that we were
given that really set out my philosophy
and approach towards my thesis and it
was an essay called a thousand plateaus
by duluz and guitare our western model
for knowledge and society is based on a
tree structure which have a seed a root
and branches and leaves that are all
traceable back to the origin a rhizome
is a plant structure that grows
horizontally and vertically in all
directions when rhizomes are separated
each piece can become a new plant a
rhizome doesn't have a central point or
a particular origin and for to losing
atari the rhizome is the model for the
post-modern world because it describes
research and thinking that allows for
multiple
non-hierarchical entry and exit points
the internet would be a great example of
this
it doesn't really have a point of origin
and
nothing can really control or shape it
or organize it its only rule is that it
grows you can take out any link or any
website without really damaging or
changing the internet it just exists
this kind of set the tone for our thesis
here just
general
confusion an architectural thesis is a
independent design research on a topic
selected by the student the student can
explore issues that he or she has
personal interests in and it's also an
opportunity to identify and elaborate on
a position within the field of
architecture
and for most people it's the final test
the culmination of their architectural
studies in the formal education system
some people have a pretty good idea what
they want to focus on but i started my
thesis here pretty clueless
and confused
and without
any vague idea of what direction i
wanted to go in
my masters was split into two years
the first was designed to explore all
the different avenues we could delve
into and exploring the different methods
of conducting research and methods of
communicating our ideas
and in the second year we narrowed down
on a topic
and we were kind of
swallowed
by this black hole called design
research and i'm gonna walk you through
the seven projects that i did in my
first year which all eventually led to
my thesis topic
so our very first assignment was all
about learning about thousands of
different perspectives in the
architectural discourse
and seeing which ones pulled our
interest and
starting to explore different methods of
representing our ideas
and this was the year of the chicago
biennial
[Music]
we were to pick three firms that were
participating and try to synthesize
their work and try to create some
connection between their work through a
medium of our choice this was in
preparation for our actual trip to
chicago where we would see the works in
person so for me
and for someone as indecisive as me
this felt like a monumental challenge
and i mean there's so many interesting
firms out there and like how do i know
what i'm interested in and what if i
pick the wrong firms does that mean i'm
gonna pick the wrong thesis topic
but
in the interest of deadlines and the
fear of failing
i forced myself to pick three that kind
of piqued my interest
and i'm not going to dwell on any
specific ideas or firms for the sake of
time of this video but feel free to
pause the video if you
want to read a more in-depth description
so the three firms were
liam young
studio detail
and i way
the project you could pick any medium
you wanted to and for my project i
decided to make a short video so that
week i opened up premiere for the very
first time i tried to learn the program
while at the same time trying to
make a project so after three days of
pure
frustration this is what i produced
[Music]
[Music]
when you think of the romantic image of
an architect you think of them drawing
day and night on their drafting board
coming up with these brilliant ideas but
in reality
a huge chunk of our time is actually
spent looking at books magazines and the
internet for inspiration
and that leads to a message from today's
sponsor hp a mouse is only a tool
but it is such an essential tool for the
modern day creative because it really
really is an extension of your hand
hp's new 930 creator wireless mouse is a
customizable mouse for architects or
creative professionals and it has seven
reprogrammable buttons that you can set
up shortcuts to and i've been really
loving this mail so far because it's
compatible with a lot of the softwares
that i use like sketchup photoshop and
of course chrome for when i'm scouring
through the internet for ideas it might
not seem like a lot but those few extra
seconds that i save with the shortcuts
those seconds really add up and add
efficiency to my workflow it connects to
bluetooth pretty seamlessly and it
allows you to connect to multiple
devices across mac os and pc by just
clicking this button the battery life on
this thing is insanely good a full
charge can last up to 12 weeks and
actually since i got it a couple months
ago i actually haven't had to charge
even once
ah
chicago
if there was one word to describe the
city it will be
grand
it is the birthplace of the skyscrapers
and the home of the greats over the time
span of a week we explore chicago and we
tour the main architectural gems like
the roby house the farnsworth house and
the crown hall by the one and only mies
van der rohe
the topic of this 2015 chicago biennial
was the state of the art in architecture
and architects were invited to share
their approach and their research
interest on some of the most
uh pressing topics
then i came across the work of brianni
roberts studio
their project was a site-specific
installation in collaboration with the
south shore drill team the drill
routines responded to the geometry and
order of mies van der rohe's federal
plaza the federal plaza is highly
ordered by the architecture and systems
of security
the mesian grid as people call it
dictates everything from pavers to the
facade
and also the security bollards the south
shore drill team is a youth organization
for kids in marginalized communities
where they train them with precise
routines combining military movements
with street choreography
and this structured program is a way to
keep the kids away from trouble these
are kids who are typically unwelcomed in
spaces of government and architectural
prestige
but during this performance they kind of
own the space
so i became really interested in this
idea of how the two systems of order can
be superimposed you can attempt to
invert and activate some of these really
formal grids and arrangements and engage
them in a new light and by doing this
it can kind of confront some of the
political and architectural ideas behind
something like the federal plaza
the projects of typological cannibalism
explicitly challenge the validity of
existing types to generate new urban
composites while renovations often aim
for respectful continuity with existing
architecture typological cannibalism
contrasts old and new to foreground the
need for typological revision
the next step was to establish your
convictions and represent them in the
form of architecture you could basically
do any kind of project that would
represent your convictions oh and you
have to make a comic strip
i was still pretty unsure of what i
wanted to do and what my conviction was
at this point but i didn't know that i
wanted to do something that challenged
the status quo in architecture the
status quo could be
represented by a typology a typology is
a building type that's become
replicated over and over and over again
to become recognizable by anyone across
different cultures
and here's my conviction
in order to create sustainable
lifestyles for the future we must not
only focus on creating efficient systems
for conservation and consumption but
also aim to actively engage users in the
understanding of urban
ecologies seeing the city as a
repository for cultural memory i
position ideas of sustainability through
the densification of urban areas and
creates new typologies amongst existing
structures the method of typological
cannibalism differs from adaptive reuse
as it aims to shock users into noticing
their new environments leading to
discomfort awareness and inspiration
this approach looks to deepen social
interactions while turning the elusive
idea of sustainability into tangible
realities
by the way i really hate how i was
writing at this time did i mention that
it's so freaking convoluted and
unnecessarily wordy and distanced and
impersonal
and nobody talks like this but
this is the methodology in which we
converse and construct systems of
knowledge in the intellectual world of
academia no
if i were to reword this in a way that
makes it accessible for everyone
it might go something like this
sustainability is not only about
creating physical systems for
conservation of energy
it is the process of engaging users to
understand and love their environment
the city is a complex organism full of
memory and culture and by working with
existing structures orders and
typologies
we can create new interactions
meanings and memories
typological cannibalism differs from
adaptive reuse and that it guides users
into noticing their new environments
leading to discomfort self-awareness and
awareness of his or her surroundings and
hopefully
inspiration
sustainability starts at the level of
the people
see how i'm making this a little bit
more personal and a little less didactic
i always try to use the pronoun we
i think it creates a sense of community
and
us
achieving this thing together also i
added the word hopefully
because this is something we can propose
but we can't really enforce
and i think it kind of leaves things
open-ended and open for conversation
and conversation's always good but
actually maybe the best way to explain
this concept is through my comic strip
[Music]
so how do you translate that into
architecture so this is the stage where
we possibly make the biggest leap from
idea to design